right good afternoon councilors members
of the staff members of the I was going
to say public but uh ccos and those
who've joined us on uh the live stream
welcome to this meeting of the um
Community wellbeing committee
I have apologies from councilor Campbell
and councilor Soper for the Council of
serper for lateness haven't heard
anything from councilor Scout would
somebody like to move that those two
apologies councilor partner in councilor
Boyle but they're all in favor against
Kerry nobody attending via Zoom which
brings us to the public forum second uh
section and welcome back Rebecca
amundsen who's um near the brief us on
the just transitions Community work
streams welcome Rebecca
I won't brief you on the process
um just for clarification I'm here today
and my role working on the community
capability building work stream under
just transitions not in my role under
the Beyond 2025 work stream
um which is where I'm now working
so
just as a wee bit of background just
transitions as you know came to
Southland probably about 18 months ago
and there's seven work streams under
that one of them is called the
capability Community capability building
work stream and a working group was put
together that included myself at the
beginning of last year to oversee that
work stream we promptly changed the name
of it to strong communities
because we wanted to better reflect what
the purpose of the work stream was so
the purpose of the work stream is about
building resilience in our communities
and we thought that capability building
sounded a bit jargony but strong
communities is ultimately what we all
want to see and so that was the name
that we went with so as part of that
process we went through a period of
community engagement and that was done
in April and May last year it that
engagement included some Community
conversations around the region as well
as some online and That Was Then
followed by a future search conference
so basically a future search conference
is when you have about 50 people in a
room and you talk about the big Wicked
issues and try and come up with a plan
for solving them basically and in our
case the work stream was charged with a
couple of activities and one of them was
to develop a vision and framework for
Community capability building for
Southland and I'm just going to did this
paper get circulated
so um
this is the framework that we came up
with and basically uh the vision was
that everyone in Southland was connected
and valued that ultimately seemed like
the feedback that everybody was giving
us
um and the most important thing uh and
then from there we had some really
strong pillars so antino rangatiratanga
was one of them in communication was
another one so that was a really strong
message that came through that there's
lots of people working in the community
and social sector and they're not very
well connected and they often are
working on their own especially people
who are working as Volunteers in the
next more the community side of of the
sector and that it was really hard for
them to find out what was going on to
get help to access information sometimes
and there was a real need for doing
something to help alleviate that some of
the other important things about the
framework that we developed was that we
based basically stole the guiding
principles from inspiring communities so
some of you might know of inspiring
communities they work in the community
lead development space across New
Zealand and they have some really good
principles and we thought we didn't need
to reinvent those so we just took them
which is what they want you to do by the
way and we also had some outcomes that
we wanted to see so communities are
resilient and people feel connected that
there's equity and access for everyone
to participate in be heard that people
have pride and feel welcome and are
welcoming and that people feel like they
can participate in their community and
in conversations about the things that
affect them so that's basically the the
framework that we developed
as part of that process within went on
to develop our project and that's what
I'm here to talk to you about today so
the project we have called connected
mirahiku and basically it is to solve
that problem around Community Connection
that that I've already mentioned that
came out as a really strong theme from
the people that we were talking to
basically the uh the the way we're going
to solve that problem is a way that lots
of other places around New Zealand have
done it so there's lots of examples you
can go on to the Community Network
aotearoa website and you can see lots of
places around New Zealand have platforms
similar to this we have basically
modeled ours on one from taranaki called
The Wheelhouse which is primarily an
online platform with a person that
oversees that platform and kind of is
the person who's responsible for
responding to needs and things that come
up through the platform so it's a
basically an online platform
it is a place where you can find
resources it's a place where you could
subscribe to an email list and get
regular newsletters that update you with
things that are happening in the
community
and across Southland and we're hoping
that it will also be a place where as
needs in the community kind of rise to
the surface that people will be able to
use that and sort of quickly connect
with each other and be able to start to
work towards
um you know addressing those needs or
issues that come up
um let me check my notes so we have a
small amount of funding from MB that we
can use to finance
um this platform over the next three
years uh and their request is that we
have some co-funding um to go alongside
that so I've been talking to funders and
other stakeholders across Southland
about the platform
and as part of that the funding could be
support and kind or resource and kind so
it doesn't necessarily need to be cash
um and the website would basically have
a coordinator
um in charge of it and their job would
be to kind of go out and find the
information
um to coordinate in-person Hui because
we think that that's a really good or an
important part of it and certainly the
feedback we got from people who came to
our two and a half day conference whilst
they all said it was a huge commitment
and it was and we were really
appreciative that people took the time
to be able to do that that the
opportunity to meet with other people
working in the community and social
sector
um that they hadn't met before was
really valuable and that's what kept
everybody coming back each day which we
were really proud of and so we think
that that sort of thing needs to carry
on at least once or twice a year
alongside again other Hui that might be
in response to community needs or things
that come up
um you know over time and you know
there's probably lots of examples of
things like that so we think that it's
going to be a great tool for the
community
and as I said you can have a look on the
community aotearo community Network LT
at our website and you can see all of
the other kind of organizations and lots
of them have different
um ways of being members or different
ways that they operate some of them
operate from actual places and have
actual an actual Hub we're not proposing
that at this stage but we do propose
that we have a governance group and in
the last term that went to the Merrell
forum and the mural Forum recommended a
joint committee structure as the
governance group with not just people
from councils but also stakeholders from
wider organizations involved and we used
a community-led approach to develop this
project and it would be our hope that
that governance group would continue to
take a community-led approach so whilst
the project itself is well relatively
small and narrow in its scope at the
moment that's based on the amount of
funding that we've got access to we hope
that over time as the platform becomes
more and more valuable to the community
and social sector that it can grow and
develop and you know and respond to the
needs of the community where's the
person based Rebecca at this stage that
is an unknown but we do have a couple of
options of places where they might be
able to have a temporary office
and and bearing in mind that I'm
guessing ICC would be approached to be
one of the financial or in-kind
stakeholders
um how much you were expecting from us
um we don't actually have a dollar
figure on it at the moment
we're just still working through some of
the finer details of how the funding
from MB will be received but we're kind
of hoping that that will be funded in
the first instance by MB and then
further down the track it would be a
variety of stakeholders okay so I mean
you'll know our process with annual plan
and we're in that budgeting stage at the
moment so it was are we going to need to
know now for the next year or is it that
the MB funding will get you through that
first year
um yes so I think the MB funding will
probably almost get us through the first
year welcome councilor Soper
thank you other questions counselors
Grant yeah thanks chair
um I'm interested with if the program's
implemented what what what would success
look like what would I see that would
demonstrate
um you know Community capability or
resilience in the community yeah I think
one of the most important things about
this opportunity is being able to
network and connect organizations and
people who are working in the community
more easily so I'm thinking about what's
happening in the North Island right now
um and you know in the places where
Community organizations are well
connected and they know who's doing what
and how and why they can respond much
more quickly everybody kind of knows
their Lane and that kind of thing and so
that's the kind of thing that I would
expect that we would be able to see here
once we have a tool like this because
everybody will know you know I need to
recommend this to you because that's
what you need and you know all of those
kinds of things
there's a part of me that sonically says
why don't we have that now
and I don't mean that disrespectfully I
mean it's it's easy to say that all
these organizations they have different
names and objectives should be talking
to each other but it's a fact that
actually they're so busy delivering that
they that they don't yeah and one of the
comments that somebody made is that
there's lots of dots doing stuff all
over Southland but they're not very well
connected yet
um and I think that's the key part and
it actually takes a lot of capacity to
be the person that is connecting
everything and if you're a volunteer
organization or an organization that's
reliant on funding you know your funding
goes to the
um the meat of what you do and some of
that other stuff whilst it would be
great to be able to do that and have
capacity to do that you don't always
um do you have a time frame around this
um so our proposal has to go to um MB by
the end of this month and uh we've been
working quite closely with them so I
would hope that means they
um they are very well aligned to what
we're proposing and then I guess from
there it just depends on what uh what
they say are the rules for dishing out
the money yeah
but you can you can go ahead once you
get there you've got the capacity to
start putting this together yeah
absolutely
well you know who the players are yes
just getting them in the room yep
any other questions counselors
it's an ambitious oh sorry Evelyn
it's just the previous
sort of in kind are we talking about are
we talking about actual things like
um technology
um
equipment or whatever but the the
Practical means that you don't have to
spend them MB dollars on Furnishing an
office for example that's right
um or
some technical support or
um those sorts of things is that part of
what you're looking at with yes
certainly so we're thinking um that
in-kind support could be
um office space for example or the use
of technology or Vehicles because
um this is a Southland wide project so
this person will you know travel around
the region so maybe it's the use of a
um a vehicle
um it could also be other things like
the main cracks of the website is to
promote and highlight what's going on in
the community already so
um I think the example I kind of use is
you get lots of newspaper articles about
the great things that are happening but
for the people who do those things those
articles don't tell you how those things
happen and that's the kind of thing so
I'm thinking that some organizations
might have coms capacity where they
might be able to write some of those
articles or some of those think pieces
that could be useful tools on the
website for example
thank you Mr Tania just one more
question we're just citizens advice
that's within this new
um piece of work with us you have yeah
that's a good question
um so citizens advice do have a quite an
extensive database of organizations
um and I guess we're kind of looking at
being something more than a database
where you know as I was talking about
more providing that kind of support so
for example
um you know if you're doing something in
the community and you're stuck on
something who do you ask to help you so
you might go on to this you might send
an email to this person who's looking
after the platform they might be able to
put you in touch with somebody who could
Mentor you
um or you know those kinds of activities
like that so that means you'll be
connecting with the community and
voluntary sector which is the theater so
you'll be yes yeah yeah
thank you any further questions
if not thanks Rebecca thanks for coming
along best of luck with the project and
please keep us up to date alongside what
goes on through the mural for thank you
councils that brings us to the minutes
of the committee meeting from
24th of January somebody want to move
that they are
confirmed
Leslie and knobby put that all in favor
against carried
minutes of the community wellbeing fund
subcommittee from
January 26th
Trish you're wanting to move those yes I
will thank you so you can do it
you're on that committee yes you are
thanks any questions
or comments you're wanting to raise
trash
I'll put that then all in favor I am
against
carried
and uh the extraordinary Community
wellbeing committee from Tuesday January
31st that we confirm those so remember
in second and moved Evelyn and seconded
Leslie
any matters are rising
if not I'll put that all in favor
against carried which brings us to
immediate old activities report actually
um
Trudy welcome along
uh so I'll just speak to the customer
and environment side of this report and
then defer to my colleague Mr gibbling
uh you'll see that December is
traditionally a quieter month for our
staff on the front line that's due to
the legal close down that occurs prior
to Christmas which is not not the close
down of our service but legally the
clocks stop for consenting just to give
you some background to that it also
includes limbs as well
and so we do traditionally see a quieter
time most solicitors close which again
stops a property settlements etc etc
but and we're also continuing to see
this less of a face-to-face interaction
for payments and transactions
coming through our centers there's
nothing concerning me in these results
in fact I'm pleased to see that our
planning consents have improved from the
previous year in terms of returning
those non-notified within 20 business
days
uh and that's a reflection on the hard
work from the team uh also uh our limbs
are still well within four days on
average of getting out which is again a
reflection on the team and just want to
um compliment our staff and Bluff they
have a great service that they provide
to the community that's multifaceted
and that helps the community remain
connected through banking through Lotto
through New Zealand post and also gives
them a library and retail outlet quite
happy to take any questions on the
Sigmund or Mr gibbling I'll be just on
the animal control one
um so on the it's on
page nine in the board books um the
figures on the right hand side with 2022
don't sort of quite add up so you've got
20 impounded and 17 dogs return but no
re-home so we so that could cross over
from a previous month
yeah so
it just happened in a month it's a
discreet month so you might have a dog
that was in there from the 31st of uh
um November yeah the month before so
it's hard to comment on that okay but
the majority of animals are either
re-homed or returned to their owners
where they're chipped and easy to
establish okay yep thank you
thank you other questions on that
section
if not thanks Trudy
Steve thanks Mr chairman councils um
this is
this is a similar themed report around
that the work our teams are doing to
engage with the community
our participation rates as you see
whilst are variable across this last
couple of months of reporting we still
haven't got back to pre-covered levels
and that's across that's for a variety
of reasons but the team are really
looking at ways across the library
Services across our our venues the pools
and
um hey wakatuia are looking at ways in
which we can continue to engage and get
different types of Engagement with our
community I think that's best example by
the reporting around the it access and
the provision of I.T Services out of the
library and in different ways in which
people are accessing our catalog in our
collection there and it really comes
down to the degree of Partnerships in
our community and again you know some of
these the developments out of bluff and
the basketball court area and also the
BMX tracker good examples of the
community and Council working in
Partnership to get a better outcome for
the community so yeah
Steve I'm not sure that you'd be able to
answer it now it'd be interesting if it
could come to the next committee meeting
though around the library I'd be Keen to
know what statistics are for new to
Young users whether or not they're still
uh young people who are wanting to
engage with it whether that's coming in
and and actually uplifting books or
whether that it's making use of of
Digital Services if we can find that
that would be interesting
other questions counselors and Grant
yeah thanks chair just a similar vein in
terms of interesting around your
community outreach program at the prison
um
but young people
um you know what outreach are we doing
to them and if we're trying to develop
up numbers it'll be interested to
understand the potential barriers to
some parts of our community around use
of the library if it's you know getting
to the library or whatever it is that
you know because engaging those young
people in the library is a really
important piece of their
world of Discovery isn't it
thank you councilor that's a great
question I think the library term are
actually pulling together a new strategy
for the service and one of those areas
that we've really focused in on is how
do we reach our young people and that's
you know our teenage and our um and our
young adult markets
um that that's certainly in terms of the
the percentage of members they are the
members that are the lowest out of our
community we've got very strong
engagement and young children and family
groups and older adults but it's that
that's that teenage and young adult
Market that's um that's the challenge
for us and the library service in
particular yeah I was actually thinking
about the younger people not the teenage
Market in the sense of it'll be
interesting to break down those numbers
is that the same family is coming
repeatedly so we or are we you know it's
an opportunity for us to get greater
reach under the Community with you know
new people that are young members coming
to the library versus the same people
coming repeatedly so some of that sort
of data would be interesting I can bring
that advice back to the next meeting I
know the team are looking at the degree
of active users out of the percentage of
community and who aren't those active
users and where do they come from
Leslie
I've
saying I did notice the summer reading
challenge had a 116 increase in the
registrations which is that young Market
in 116 percent
increase even taking into account
influence
is very high for that
um
so and I know that summer reading
programs go on for many many years so
I'm just wondering whether there's
almost a steer there that we need more
traction programs of that sort whether
it's a winter reading program or
whatever it may be and I'd also be
interested in the e-book breakdown have
we got a an age break down there are we
getting more interest from the younger
market and the e-book
axis we have sought the in the ebook
area we we are trying to dig out the
demographics of who are the key users
there I guess what we can see and with
the stats we do have is that the usage
is increasing we just don't know
how old that market is or what segment
of the market it is so we are we are
looking into that so we can get better
targeted Communications and promotions
yeah because I noticed it's ebook end
see if we can bring a break down there
Evan did you have a question
I do
um
and it's just around where the location
of the
bus hub is currently has it had an
impact of the library think on those
people who
go there because if you're dependent on
transport to come into town you're
dropped off because there's nowhere else
in the area to stop except it
it's the nearest one to the library for
some people is that a barrier do we know
has there been
an effect of the relocation of the Hub
not aware of any feedback that's come
through the library but again I can
probably work with my writing colleagues
to understand whether or not that's
feedback that's come through the
passenger transport program
if I can bring that advice back I will
Peter then Trish yeah thank you chair I
just wonder with all the um
Road works and developments going on
around the
I know a lot of other businesses are
really suffering because of the lack of
car parking and I just it may have
something to do with a downturn
and the numbers going to our library
we will soon know in the next few months
what the library does have its very own
car park attached to it I know but a lot
of people pack it
in other streets too apart from the car
parking rolling
in terms of ebooks I know that schools
active
Act of all a lot of them all have
e-accounts I know my granddaughter
taught me how to get an E1 because she
leaves at school so I do think that
there's
um in the education of the community
they really work hard at it readings
reading you know and and the advantage
of an ebook at night is you can flip it
around and have a black background with
white text which is very handy for not
waking up the person next to you yeah
you can get it anywhere
knobby
um yes sir reflection Steve on the comms
data that we've got on there
um
to a lay person reading this this is
hard work let's find it to get your head
around some of these figures I'm not
suggesting I'm a lay person but it's
just that um
in some places we talk about the number
of people engaging with the website and
then we talk about how many pages they
actually look at which is a page count
and as I'm working through this I see
some
some areas where our um
um the figures don't correlate as you go
through the reports so don't want to
explore that takers unless you're
looking at it it would be hard for
anybody to probably do but I just think
that's an area to look at that really
really pleasing if the if the user
contact is up to 20 something thousand
from previously I think about ten
thousand that's a good look
um that we're reaching out to that many
people
um so just some clarification it'd be
helpful the other issue for me was on
the issue of
um
uh the collection that you've currently
got sitting in there and it talks about
moving to uh tesbury uh and November I
have two questions about that
um one is the issue of how long do you
think it'll take to move the collection
from the pyramid to tesbury
any ideas on it uh we're working to a
current program it's just under four
months
okay and the other issue is the issue of
um disposing of some of the uh artifacts
that we no longer required I know how
complex it is but that will surely
need to be a priority if we don't want
to get a situation we don't have enough
space in the current it does bring forth
what we actually need long term
and so is this some way of doing that is
there some way that you might for
argument's sake take some stuff that you
think is no longer required out of the
pyramid but not to Tisbury where it can
be worked on about tracing who the
people are that initially donated and
where they can be disposed of pretty
confident the de-excisioning was well
underway before Smeg
changed its its structure so all that
stuff had been identified and was was
going through that process so that that
didn't happen
so just out of curiosity then what some
level of disposable we have in that area
percentage-wise do you think
look I I would I wouldn't want to has it
again because I'd be wrong
um mayor Clark so that's something that
we could look to bring back I think it's
a separate briefing I think that would
be helpful because we don't want a
situation where
um we we have too much for what we've
built at Tisbury I guess that's what I'm
alluding to
if I can reflect back to the
communications figures for a moment it
is a little bit of a Dark Art and I'm
not sure how you can simplify it bearing
in mind that I work in this sphere as
well and that our website stuff is
really quantifiable because we own all
those clicks but when you get into the
measurements around social media it's
Impressions versus engagement and
anytime you scroll past something it's
an impression actually whether you
looked at it or not the stuff that you
really want to measure are engagements
there's a lot of people will throw at
impression figures which sounds
impressive but it's like how many people
looked at that page of the South and
times in its organic form but did you
read every article on it so I guess it's
a it's a new addition it's only our
second meeting having these figures
available and
I guess it's a case of watching to see
how those Trends move the numbers uh are
intriguing but it's when you notice uh
severe changes up or down trying to
understand what they are and helping to
identify the areas that are working and
those that could work better
but it is it is a learning process
I guess I guess what it's alluding teach
here was the uh
the fact that we've got some healthy
increase certainly in the unique users
which are BFS protocol to know that
people are looking
and once they start and in one one area
are unique uses of basically stayed
static on another area they've gone up
significantly which is healthy that's
the later ones the truth but then what
they're looking at a bit confusing I
guess like you say I guess the first
Port of Call is to break it down so we
know where it reaches are trying to
quantify what they're looking at it's a
different killer fish again
easy on our website yeah a little harder
with social media sure thank you great
yeah it just things cheer just through
the with regard to the communication
it'd be interesting to get feedback
around
any organizations volunteer that we've
helped with their Communications then
given them communication support around
telling their story or is there
opportunities for us to do that
in the community going forward like is
that where we're going to head to around
using our skills in our community
Communications team to help yeah
connected volunteer organizations get
better outcomes for their
I would like them to do with what we
need first
it is it is a limited uh pull but I
think it's something Lisa that we we
look
oh sorry Trudy uh that we look to see
whether that where there are synergies
and what we're actually engaged with and
able to further help
Trudy or Lisa whoever's willing yes at
the moment though we don't have a lot of
capacity in the com space in fact where
sometimes
things are beyond our capacity but in a
perfect world uh yes we would like to be
able to tell stories and we do that
through the grants program at the moment
so some of the pieces there in the
well-being grants you'll see the stories
of those and the Heritage committee
about the stories where we have
connected in a different way so we
always will try to work with the
community when it's not just an ICC
project or event
thank you
any further questions or comments on the
activity reports
crap yeah
yeah thank you um with respect to the
tracks and Trails
um it's great to see you know those
resources being used because I think
they're fabulous resources we've got in
our community
I'd be interested in the numbers around
who's using them for the first time or
again are they just repeated users and
because to me there's a real benefit to
our community the more people that use
those facilities because they are such
great facilities so any comment on that
you thank you councilor
um because of the nature of the way in
which we do track counting it doesn't
capture demographics it's just basically
you have walked past yeah yeah on the
spot and it just doesn't it just counts
a number rather than who that number is
now we do the satisfaction kpi reporting
as well and that's a new element that's
being rolled out and that will be coming
to an upcoming
committee meeting on the first quarter's
reports on the Sydney quarters reports
of programs so
we do get a sense of
satisfaction but we don't we can't get
into that level of detail unless we
specifically ask
that's not something we're asking for at
the moment yeah because given Community
well-being and resilience is really
really important
you know I think
it's something we need to be thinking
about how we attract more people to
those places
and they get the benefits of those
final question Stephen I'm not sure if
you can answer it but when
um is the new development down start
with the shifting of the BMX direct from
where it was to up on the hill Windsor
completed yeah
curiosity
any other questions
if not then I could have somebody move
that we received the report
knobby and Leslie thank you put that all
in favor
aye against Kerry that brings us to the
public excluded session and just to note
that apart from the confirmation of
minutes from
uh January 24 and the receiving of the
PE section of the community wellbeing
fund January 23 item C which is the
splash Palace reduction of weekend
operating hours there's been a change in
the public excluded reasons for the
report being in PE
um the previous reasons uh were around
seven to a
um and seven two B two and the amendment
is now around seven to one or seven two
I which is to enable any local Authority
holding the information to carry on
without prejudice or disadvantage
negotiations including commercial and
Industrial negotiations
so with that Amendment to the third item
uh could I have somebody move that we go
into public excluded ringing and Evelyn
I'll put that all in favor against
carried thanks to those who've been on
the live stream we now go